good morning nation my name is Evan
Carmichael my one word to believe as I
believe that entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help encourage earning today's message
is turned your weaknesses into your
strengths over you John chuckles a
person's strengths are often their
biggest weaknesses and so that also
means that their weaknesses can be their
strengths so me I am weak in all those
ways that I listed I am weak but I don't
accept that I don't accept that I am
what I am and that that is what I'm
doing to be no I don't accept that
I'm fighting I'm always fighting I'm
struggling and I'm scrapping and kicking
and clawing at those weaknesses to
change them to stop them
some days I win some days I don't but
each and every day I get back up and I
move forward with my fists clenched
toward the battle toward the struggle
and I fight with everything I've got to
overcome those weaknesses and those
shortfalls and those flaws as I strive
to be just a little bit better today
than I was yesterday
I don't really spend a lot of time
thinking about my weaknesses I think
it's important to have the awareness to
know what you're not good at to know
that Microsoft advocate review might
suck it feels the marketing there you
might not be great front of the camera
you might not want to you know write
copy like you're not good at these
things it's good to know what you're
good at and know what you're a great
actor so you can focus your time this is
your goal right you're going to focus as
much time on the things that you can
potentially one of the greatest people
in the world Act I'm not a big fan of
focusing on improving your weaknesses I
think you have people who you're great
at this one thing right like you can be
up here shining like a star you've got
Michael Jordan geez double talents as
this and you suck at all these other
things and you either focus your time
try to improve all these things that
you're not good at and spend time and
improvement work with them and slowly
get better and maybe get average results
or you can ignore all this stuff and
focus on this and be amazing at it I
want to be up here I don't want to focus
down in the world reward the people who
play up here the world rewards the
people who are amazing at something can
provide an same value when something
right you get success of providing value
to people if you are average and a whole
bunch of things you're not really
providing the love that but if you're
great at this one thing if you are the
world's greatest mechanic you can
provide a ton of value to people you can
make a ton of money you're going to be
huge impact because you are the world's
greatest mechanic or surgeon or
basketball player or coder or
videographer or whatever it is you could
be great at and who cares if you can't
sing or if you suck at math or if you
don't know your Kennedy well if your
spelling is all right for me this stuff
doesn't matter focus up on here and I
think too much we talked about I'm going
to work on our weaknesses
improve these things and it's a noble
effort but the biggest factor is an
opportunity cause you're taking away
from doing this English to bring you
take away from spending your time up
here being a star work at your craft
because how can a natural talent isn't
enough you could be the world's greatest
mechanic but you need to practice
Michael George might be the wolf serious
basketball player picking cotton every
day to practice he practicing practicing
practicing the first one that come in in
the last early but all the cliches you
were taught and that time we all the
point where I wonder the day that time
you miss offended at doing non
basketball stuff and he didn't care
about without the leverage even though
you might have natural talent for
basketball because he wasn't working at
hard was it a success so I think you
need to have self-awareness to
understand what your weaknesses are and
the best entrepreneurs in the world
understand that they know what they're
great at and they know what they
actually suck and what they create ask
is usually one or two or three things
that's it like really tiny little things
that's what they're great actors and
then they built up a team to support
them in all here is different we've done
so I guess in my time to doing what I
love to do what I could be world's best
at essentially I'm not working for I
look at the TV channel when I started
into the zombie and you have to have
that approach that you're gonna dominate
yourself I don't think an army of one I
will try to enlist help get people to
volunteer their time try to give people
one more to what I'm doing but if I
can't at the start cuz I don't want to
spend money on making money I'll be
hungry one I won't will it into
existence
I will just create it I will do
everything I will film it I will edit it
I'll be in front of the camera behind
the camera research changed publishing
everything but I realized that my
strengths and what I want to get better
at is going to be the stuff in front of
the camera not behind I don't really
want to learn how to be a better
photographer I don't really want to
learn how to position the lights I'd be
the best lighting guy in the world I
don't really want to learn about
different microphones of the technology
and all the stuff using the Sam's I
don't really want to learn about a lot
of the stuff that has to do with my
future
I want to be in front of a camera be as
good as it can be and practice and work
hard to make thousands of videos five
thousand videos I've made to improve to
get better to work on my craft and I
want to prove everything that goes up on
and make sure that passes mycology can I
see every video that we have in four
launches and said yes I'm proud of it I
would show my grandkids this this is
happens we have an architect and I want
to keep raising the bar on that and for
me to focus my time on making more
videos and practice my skills and to
review the videos are coming in the
amount of time that that takes I can't
be spending it on other stuff when I was
willing everything on myself I was lucky
to make one video a month and eventually
moved to one video only maximum because
I was doing everything and then as I
hired my first person was an editor as a
blooper video a week to video with it
and as I started building up some more
team as I make more money then I could
hire more people and I could make more
videos to two a days and I'll free it
so think about three videos a day versus
one video a week how much better am I
going to get for the camera a little
better right
how many more videos I'm gonna have to
review to keep raising the bar the
quality and hold my eye on what I think
makes a good video right I'm getting the
repetitions into a muscle get stronger
and get better at the thing that I want
to get better at work you're not
spending any of your time if you're
swimming interest of your time 95
working the things that you suck assets
try to get a mediocre level and only
five the quantitative the type of things
that you have the Kingston says star at
you can with interruptions you know
we're going to get they're going to be a
catch effect and I want you to have an
allergic reaction being average I want
you to find the thing you have the
amazing abilities of shining eyes to be
Michael Jordan level Catalan genius L
account at and try to spend as much time
doing that as possible put in the reps
so you can feel like you're having a big
impact so you can feel like you're
growing you're making a lot of money
you're doing a lot of damage in your
industry and you fulfill
so the question thing today is to part I
want to know what your greatest strength
is and what your greatest weakness is as
well leave it on the comments below I
also want to give a quick chance to
Gavin Anderton Jackson thank you so much
for picture of a cup of my both your own
words
I really appreciate support and I hope
you enjoyed the one so thank you guys so
much for watching I will see would you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
and I'll see you again far more in for
another shot of espresso
[Music]
knowing your strengths and weaknesses
and knowing what you enjoy doing you
know if you look at it as a job you've
already lost it it's not going to be
your passion and you're going to count
the hours if you look at it as something
you love to do um and then you know what
your strengths are then you can leverage
those strengths in your business and in
helping others and once you recognize
your weaknesses then you can work with
people that compliment you I mean every
one of my businesses I've had a partner
who's very anal Martin Woodall Todd
Wagner incredibly anal people
perfectionist because I'm a slob you
know I'm a big-picture think about
what's around the corner how is
technology going to change things how
can I change you know this industry and
you know making sure that there's
somebody there to make to dot the i's
cross the t's and keep me in the bass
lines Elm and you know recognizing my
weaknesses is just as important as
recognizing my strengths my core
competencies and and you know having a
passion to do being intuitive is
important and then surround yourself
with really smart business people that
can support your weaknesses know what
they are I know I don't know how to
create an e-commerce platform I'm well
aware of that
so I surrounded myself with people who
can and who do do that and then as far
as mentors go
countless I really I was not shy about
making phone calls to many people I've
been fortunate enough to know people
like Tory Burch and dive-bomb
Furstenberg and they you know got lots
of emails and phone calls for me along
the way with tears in my eyes saying I
don't know if this is possible why is
everyone telling me no what do I do
what does even mean to go to get venture
towel what is venture capital with a
board like I just didn't know all these
business terms and so they they helped
me understand it it's very important and
I also come back
Ches to learn how to recognize your own
strengths and witnesses this is in fact
the vital part of preparation for a big
match and for anything alive we always
try to study our opponents we always try
to try to study the battlefield we
always try to study all the
circumstances surrounding our venture
endeavor but very often we forget to
study ourselves and this is very
important because any choice of a ground
for battle or you know type of strategy
we want to employ depends on our
recognition of our strengths and
weaknesses and this is a process of
constant revaluation because life is
changing very fast and our opponents
looking at our success studying it and
trying to be to be smart and outsmart us
eventually and we can look at the
history and just to find a number of
situations were the the inability to
recognize strengths and weaknesses led
to an eventual disaster